[Music]  now I know you all remember the biggest  pop music rivalry of the late 90s right  Britney vs Christine oh well guess what  the timing may just be coincidence but  last night both Britney and Christina  made big announcements Britney's news  she's taking her Vegas show on a 23 stop  world tour starting in July Christina  who's kinda been mi a for the past two  years posted this shot from a fan asking  where the bleep is the new album she  replied it's coming here's what the 37  year old mom of two told us back in 2015  I'm big on the marination process I have  to make sure that the details are all  there I can't I'm not robotic I can't  just you know pop out pop out music  this amazing performance with Madonna  was the last time Britney and Christina  were seen together et has learned ex  Tina's new music could drop as early as  spring and as for that feud well Britt  did say this I would love to have a  voice like Christina  [Music]